so yesterday we were treated to a lot
concerning Avengers for a brand new toy
cover revealed that Thor rocket and
Captain America will get different
outfits and Avengers for nobody is 100%
sure what these outfits are for but I
personally think that it's so they can
travel inside of the quantum realm if
you want to watch the full video on why
I think these suits are for travelling
inside of the quantum realm you can
check it out in the link above also my
giveaway still continues I'm giving away
copies of Avengers infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter is subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so yesterday when we first saw
this leaked concept art for this toy of
Thor and Rocket everybody was focusing
on the suits clearly it's a really
different look and it clearly signifies
something but there are words on here
which is probably describing the toy
that nobody could really make out the
print was too small and when you zoomed
in enough the print was way too blurry
to read but as it turns out some people
were actually able to read what it said
and it could possibly reveal a lot more
about Avengers 4 than we thought here's
what the description says about the toy
the Asgardian Thor wields the mighty
storm breaker in his battle against new
foes rocket teams up with a new crew to
guard the galaxy from an even greater
threat an even greater threat are they
talking about an even greater threat
than Thanos considering the fact that
the gauntlet and Thanos are permanently
damaged after the snap and the galaxy
having half of the universe being wiped
away is left in a really vulnerable
state so there could be a bigger threat
than Thanos coming and that's what
Avengers 4 could be about Wow the Russo
brothers did say that we literally have
no idea what Avengers 4 is going to be
about and I think we all assumed that
Thanos is going to be the main villain
in Avengers 4 but what if we're wrong
Jeremy Conrad at MCU cosmic reminded us
that Fox wanted to change negasonic
teenage warhead powers in the first
deadpool movie and they needed Marvel's
permission to do so and in exchange
Marvel got back the rights to
but what if they also got back the
rights to another character in secret
and they just didn't tell us because
they knew they were going to use this
character in another movie this is very
possible and there are bigger threats
than Thanos out there so could we
possibly be seeing the Avengers team-up
within us to take on an even bigger
threat in Avengers 4 regardless of what
happens it clearly seems like there's
more to Avengers 4 than we actually know
so let me know your thoughts if a new
villain is coming into Avengers 4 to
fight the Avengers who do you think
it'll be let me know in the comments
below don't forget to subscribe like the
video and comment below with your
thoughts so you can enter the giveaway
and stay up to date with everything
relating to Avengers 4 as always thank
you so much for watching
well forth
[Music]